ich meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen zu einem video über die video
days in cologne und zwar bin ich ja
eigentlich wo nicht in hamburg aber wir
sind jetzt also max und ich sind für die
video days also für den 15 und 16 15 und
16 1516 da sind wir jetzt nach köln
gefahren sind jetzt gerade ein hotel und
werden am morgen am 15
autogramme geben und in online ein
bisschen mario kart zocken wenn wir und
am 16
dann ist er die live schauen alles
möglich das hotel ist einfach so laut
hier ja das ist direkt in der innenstadt
und die straße direkt hier
das ist so abartig na ja gut ich würde
sagen wollte jetzt einfach ein intro
wieder machen weil wir morgen halt schon
relativ früh aufstehen müssen und
dadurch halt keinen bock wenn wir also
verpennt irgendwas zu machen und wegen
würde ich sagen jetzt viel spaß bei
meinen sachen die ich beim video del
film würde ihren gleich hallo freunde
herzlich willkommen zu einem video der
video vom sonntag
gestern hab ich nichts gefällt auf der
gamescom auch mich aber auch nichts
gefällt weil ich irgendwie die kamera
einfach von jetzt auch dabei
ich denke hat im fahrstuhl von choice
hotels
echte wurde und am tag
es ist eine krankheit
am 1
der 5
wir sind hier beim gegenstand zusammen
mit kay und ich habe gerade ein rennen
gemacht
ganz vielen anderen genau und wir haben
gerade ein rennen gefahren mario kart um
ein bierchen da würde ich erst dann hat
er gesagt komm mal wieder wenn ich
gewinne hast mein bier ich länder
nächstes oder milch und wenn ich gewinne
kriegen bild in münchen
und wenn ich danach möchte er kommt noch
ein spiel wenn du jetzt gewisse zwei
berge der 1
da muss man dazu sagen wiedergewonnen
buch gehört kommt als zweiter platz in
mario kart unbesiegbarkeit sternberger
ein blitz durch gute situation jetzt
oder ja wie das ist eklig dieses tätig
ich habe es auf jeden fall gewonnen und
jetzt werden wir in die die move lang
stehen und wenn wir da schon mal ganz
ruhig laufen perfekt ok danke schön
wir können auch mal kurz ein bisschen
film
wir haben
bauer in ganz lippe
die roma
aus dem off
dafür brauche ich den klub lockt ein
stoffdach den keiner konkret was machen
wir hier
ich wollte endlich muss sagen dass das
ganze feld warten wieder das war der sog
die kann man jetzt noch die feuerwehr
personen geschlagen
er will unbedingt in meinem blog freuen
hallo ich bin der brokser radow jetzt
sehen wir ein typisches beispiel wie
wieder mal unterbunden wurde von der
kompletten organisation dass man
irgendwas mit fans machen konnte also
ich versuche jetzt hier noch zu regeln
dass ich mit ihren foto man das dann
irgendwie gemacht aber ich musste steil
weiter und das tut mir einfach leid
schuldig
man müsse jetzt endlich anständig aber
wenn's beim game
schulstress
die schnur
und
lösen
die leute das war's von video del 2014
ich konnte nicht so viel film weil wir
da wirklich von der autogrammstunde dann
wieder dahin gefördert wurden und dann
aber angst auch in dieser lage da oben
wo er auch schon aufnahmen gesehen habt
und der ganze tag war voll gepacktes
programm ich konnte es nicht viel film
ich hatte ja auch kein kameramann dabei
wie das andere youtuber irgendwie hatten
die dann alles für die gefilmt haben und
so das geschlecht und auch wenn ich dann
autogramme gegeben habe wollte ich nicht
so viel dann film und alles mögliche
deswegen das waren ganz paar einblicke
für euch von mir in meine drei tage hier
in köln ich falls wieder zurück nach
hamburg wo ich dann endlich meinen umzug
noch plan werde und dann würde ich sagen
dass ich trotzdem gefallen hat würde ich
mich definitiv für meinen daumen hoch
freuen
ja mehr filme ich gar nicht an zu sagen
ich kann nur sagen das ist mir leid dass
ich so wenig gefilmt habe und das an
oder vielmehr gefilmt haben aber naja
wir sehen uns dann einen anderen videos